president Trump's lawyer got a temporary
restraining order barring adult film
star stormy Daniels from speaking about
her alleged affair with mr. Trump the
order obtained by CBS News was issued
last week in private arbitration in
California a lawyer for Daniel's called
the order improper and hidden from
public view Paula Reid is at the White
House Polly good morning good morning
now according to this restraining order
Daniel's is bound by the terms of an
October 2016 nondisclosure agreement
that she signed which bars her from
discussing any details about her
relationship with a president in
exchange for her silence she was paid a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars by
president Trump's lawyer she also agreed
to pay a million dollars every time she
violates that agreement but on Tuesday
she filed a lawsuit claiming that
non-disclosure isn't valid because
President Trump didn't sign it details
about this new secret restraining order
only came to light yesterday after the
White House press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders said the president
denies all these allegations but then
suggested he had already won the overall
dispute with daniels in arbitration
prompting reporters to ask wait what
arbitration Noah Daniels attorney says
that the president can't possibly win
something if he's not a party he notes
that the president's name doesn't appear
on the restraining order and the
president's representatives claim the
president had no knowledge at that
original non-disclosure agreement
Daniel's attorney also takes issue with
the fact that he wasn't allowed to be
present when that restraining order was
issued to argue his client's side Norah
so Paula give us some perspective and
where do we think this is going to end
up well the first question is whether or
not that original nondisclosure
agreement is valid if the president
didn't sign it if it is valid then that
restraining order is valid too because
under the terms of that original
agreement she agreed to arbitration
possibly without notice if there were
any disputes but there's also questions
even if the courts find that the
original agreement was valid
the president's lawyer may have
invalidated it by speaking about it
publicly